hi christina
hi there
how are you
i am well how about you
good thank you
it's nice to talk to you again
it is and it is also sad to say that it
is
about the end of lucifer
i know
those times
so has the end finally really sunk in
now i mean with the show finished
filming and now doing this last round of
press to talk about the last season does
it
feel like the last season is done
um
it doesn't yet i think um like knowing
that like the show's got a drop and
talking about the show still it doesn't
feel like i've been able to truly just
like let it go yet
um but it's going to be kind of a a very
interesting day when on september 10th
when the show drops
because that's that's kind of it
um
and
i think it will slowly start to sink in
then i mean it it it feels like still
i'm i'm in new york working at the
moment but i've still had it programmed
into me that year after year i'm going
to go back to lucifer and start shooting
and i i i'm i haven't had that
experience yet i've gone oh we're not
we're not going back but i think it's
about to happen because i'm about to rap
on this job here and then um i'll be
like what's next and it's definitely not
lucifer
so
yeah so it's a strange time in my life
but but i feel very satisfied about the
last six years for sure
yeah because it must have been kind of
strange i would imagine you couldn't
have had like a big wrap party
celebration with you know doing the
shower during covered
it was that i mean that was really
yeah that was tough like not being able
to properly celebrate with everybody and
say goodbye properly
um i still feel like at some point we'll
all try and get together and and round
it off in a suitable um lucifer manner
but um
yeah it was it was it was really tough
shooting during cover and certainly
shooting the final season during kobe
because i i felt like i wasn't ever
truly able to express to the people
around me how i felt about them um
but um
but yeah hey ho at least at least we got
to do it we all felt very grateful that
we were working at the time
when was the point that you actually
found out what the
official ending of the series would be
um well when we were shooting season
five we
thought that was the final season yeah
and so i
um i sat with joe and aldi for a while
and we mused for a long time about what
the end of the show should be
um and
we all kind of agreed um
on this particular ending um and then of
course we were throwing a sort of slight
curveball at the end and then netflix
asked us to do another season but i
think that we
we have managed to preserve like the
notion and certainly the end of what we
thought the end of the show should be
um so i've sort of known
loosely how the show was going to end
for a while i the the thing that was
sort of new to me was the storyline of
season six and how we ended up getting
back to where we were
planning on ending but yeah
yeah because i just i know that you know
you had gotten that pickup announcement
during the season so things had to shift
so that's why i was curious how much
had to then added
it was very late in the day i mean it
was it was we were i remember being in
the production office and joe and hildy
came to say um do you want to hear
something funny and i was like they've
offered us another season and they were
like uh-huh
um and that we would because we'd
already kind of like broken the finale
we'd already like talked about it but it
wasn't but the writers had gone off to
like write it um so it was very very
late in the day so it was a little bit
of a kind of mental um rehash for me to
sort of get my head around it but um
yeah that feels like like
quite a long time ago now that lots of
stuff's happened since then there's been
a thing called a global pandemic since
then
i absolutely love that part of your
first episode back is set inside of the
magic castle and incorporates magic
because i'm such a magic fan myself and
sort of makes sense that lucifer would
be too since it does have that
bit of mischievous and rebellious air
about it
how did that come about were you a fan
of magic whose idea was all of that
well with um
we we have a writer on our staff called
mike costa who is a member of the magic
castle
and a huge i was into magic as proper a
magic nerd we should say um and
basically um
i think over the years we'd always you
know in the writers room they talked
about wouldn't it be great if we did an
episode here or an episode there and the
magic castle was an episode that they've
talked about for a while and never been
able to facilitate it you know within
what we've been doing that season and
then when the season six um
opportunity came in like the you know
saying do you want to do season six
i think they felt in the writers room
that finally had they had this
opportunity to do the magic castle kind
of episode that they wanted to do um so
it's been simmering away really in the
in the writers room with lucifer for a
few years but um i think mike was
absolutely delighted when it finally uh
when it finally came up and and you know
being the opening of the season as well
was a big deal yeah it's definitely a
fun episode
oh it really is yeah it's kind of it
that episode to me is a little bit like
the calm before the storm
because you've had this big kind of like
ending to season five and then this sort
of a month later not much has really
happened and we've got this sort of
period of procrastination that our
characters have been going through
um
and then they're kind of like quite a
small-ish story you know in a small
setting and intimate to start season off
but um i think it's just you know um we
needed to give ourselves somewhere to go
so it felt very appropriate
what was it like to find out about the
whole rory storyline and and know that
you'd be bringing in time travel and a
future daughter i mean what
it's sort of like all of these crazy
things what were you most excited about
with exploring with that what were you
most nervous about with putting this in
the show in the last season
um i think i
you know the when i first heard the the
time travel storyline i was like what
um
but that's not been the first time i've
had that kind of reaction to an idea
that joe and alde have pitched me um
i've been like how is that gonna have
what the um but then of course you know
we've realized that we have the luxury
within this show we have a certain
license
to kind of go crazy and zany and as long
as we all kind of commit to it then
everyone seems to come with us and we've
taken a few swings over the years and
people have really embraced
you know the kind of like swings that
we've taken so
in this case there's no reason why that
shouldn't happen as well my i guess my
one sort of like thing that we say about
being nervous about it um introducing a
new character in the final season
uh of something where people really love
our character and we're trying to round
their stories off
could be seen as a bit of a risk if you
want your audience to feel something for
that character as well
but at the same time the character that
we're introducing
um there is so much feeling for that
character from our our lead characters
basically um that
that i think that you know we are able
by proxy as an audience member to to
deeply care about this relationship
what was it like for you guys to bring
in brianna hildebrand and how did you
and laura navigate that dynamic with her
it was i mean brianna was great i loved
working with her um
she
it was interesting actually brianna is a
kind of like innately shy person
um and sort of like she's sort of hold
you know she holds her cards close to
her chest and she's a bit of an observer
she's got a wicked sense of humor
um and
i found myself like much like lucifer i
found myself as tom trying to kind of
like impress myself upon her
i kind of like you know
you know and and that sort of
that echoed both on and off screen like
trying to i always felt like i was
playing catch-up with her i just really
really wanted her to like me
and i felt you know that was a kind of
similar energy to what lucifer was going
through once he kind of caved in and
realized that this was you know their
daughter and and all of those things he
just wanted her to love him
and i um
i i was able to kind of like play that
out quite nicely with brianna because
she is you know like i say this innately
shy person she doesn't give too much
away
um but by the end of it i felt so fond
of her and i did feel like her dad was
weird how these things happen on our
show but like dennis felt like my dad
when we were shooting season five and by
the end of season six i felt like i was
brianna's dad
um and i was really kind of like proud
of her about certain things like her
singing voice for example i just
couldn't believe how beautiful it was
and i just kept wanting to tell people
how wonderful it was and so on the last
day we end up doing like a little
impromptu gig outside the trailers with
my guitar and my amp and a microphone i
just got to sing in front of people like
a very embarrassing dad
um
and um but thankfully she went along
with it
yeah i love that you get to do a duet
because it feels like there's no way
that anybody can join the show and be
part of lucifer's family if you don't
end up singing with him at some point
exactly
exactly and but also because music is so
intrinsic to lucifer it's a language to
lucifer something he truly understands
um and
for his offspring
to have inherited
that side of things and so that love of
music and just you know honestly when
brianna said to me when i heard brianna
singing for the first time i couldn't
believe how beautiful our voice was
it was truly lovely
what does it mean to him to finally get
to that point where she calls him dad
i mean it was
it was um
it was unique in terms of i haven't felt
that feeling on the set of lucifer
before and i think that that's
that sort of echoes
why what i really liked about season six
full stop is that it it was an
opportunity to explore a dynamic
that we hadn't done before we've done it
we felt like we've done touched
everywhere else but lucifer as a parent
was something i'd never sort of fathomed
um and
one thing i can say is tom as a parent
was i was able to kind of like
um delve into those feelings delve into
like what that means
and how kind of um
disarming that is
um and how you just like i was saying
before you just want that person you
just want to impress yourself upon that
person and be you know be a focal point
in that person's life
and um yeah it just it it was a
territory i didn't think we'd ever
explore but i was so glad we actually
got to do it
how did you feel about the final
decision that these characters make in
regard to you know menudial becoming god
lucifer essentially becoming hell's
therapist
what uh
what did you feel about that those final
decisions for those characters
they felt right
like i i i felt like
the sort of neat and tidy version of
lucifer would be to go and lose for at
least it goes from being the devil to be
being god but actually
i'm all about the journey and
the point of like lucifer using
his experience on earth and what he'd
learned through all these different
things rather than just going to a place
like heaven
he actually needs to take a place that
when he needs it
and realizing that souls can still be
saved after they've been damned was a
huge kind of like turning point and
lucifer kind of utilizing what he's
learned to to essentially go and do what
his calling was and run hell his way
um i loved that notion and i also felt
like amanda deal
being
um
being god just felt so appropriate
um and especially since he also had
walked with mankind he also knows what
it's like to be a father
um and i just feel like his innate kind
of wisdom and his his innate
uh presence as an angel suggested that
he would be a much stronger
um a much stronger god than lucifer
would be um
yeah
one of the most talked about aspects of
the show has been whether ella would
ever find out about lucifer
and whether she should find out how she
would react if she found out so how do
you feel about her finding out and her
reaction to finding out did you feel
like that was something that had to
happen before the end of the series
i mean again it wasn't something that i
ever felt i didn't i didn't ever think
we'd get there but again when we when
season six was was thrown in it was like
well what haven't we done
who still needs to find out what are we
gonna and
i don't think that ellen needed to find
out because one of the things we've
always loved about the ella character
over the years is that
she has this faith
and faith is the important part of
that whole equation then not knowing and
still committing and believing is the
important part of that equation so for
her to be suddenly knowledgeable that
these things that she's had of faith and
do exist was a little bit like do we
need do we need to be doing that but at
the same time these people are her
friends and ella's not ella's not um
she's not stupid she's a very
intelligent person you know she's very
brilliant at her job so i kind of feel
like
to to to lose that conceit in the final
season and give her that kind of what
does this mean to you situation i think
that was actually
um something that was really important
and something i think you know again it
was a story that we hadn't told yet
as hard as it was to lose dan to the
land of the living last season i am very
glad we got the chance to see him again
in this last season
how did you feel about that journey and
having him hang around for the season
while only some of you could see him and
communicate and interact with him
oh poor dan
i know well obviously you know when we
when we killed dan we thought that that
would only be one more episode of
lucifer after that so it was kind of
like it was a tragic kind of ending
um
you know in season five
so knowing when season six came out we
were like oh my god we've killed them
what we're going to do but of course you
know being the show we've got these
these um
this license to to really sort of play
around with the notion of the afterlife
so
having him in purgatory knowing that
lucifer would do anything he can to save
his friend and all of those things
i just i you know i was personally
delighted that we could still have kevin
in the show because he's just brilliant
um
but also it made quite a lot of sense
for our characters it also helped in
that kind of illustration and
explanation to lucifer that souls can be
saved when he finds out that dan finally
made it to heaven like that's a really
big moment and it's a really big moment
in
you know subconsciously for lucifer
realizing what hit what lucifer's actual
calling is so that whole damn storyline
really helped service that notion at the
end that souls can be saved still and
this is how you do it
um and yeah but also it was great
because kevin ended up directing two of
our episodes in the final season
and
not only is kevin an amazing performer
he's also turned into a fantastic
director um and
it was it was great on all fronts just
to um just have
kevin i would have kevin alejandro on
every day on every set if i could
were there any funny moments when he's
hanging out on set and only some people
can see him and talk to him and it just
it would make the other characters seem
crazy
we did i mean there was always moments
of like can you sit down are you able to
actually sit on a stool without falling
through it and like all these kind of
like rules that we weren't quite sure
about but i think we just sort of
committed to what felt right on the day
but um yeah it was the one thing i would
say about kevin is that like uh he was
quite happy and everyone was a bit
jealous that he got to wear exactly the
same thing for the entire season
it seems like the next
natural step after doing a musical
episode is to do an animated episode
so did you know that was something that
joe henderson had always wanted to do
had you talked about before trying to
figure out how to do that
well we we were um i think joe and i
were sort of just having a sort of
general spitballing conversation before
the season started
knowing that we had all these covered
restrictions in place
and it that again is like that and that
came out of um the obstacle of covid
and it was like how can we cut down on
you know
how can we cut down on our scripts how
can we cut down on um like time together
physically and all of these things and
then we talked about the fact that the
blacklist had just come out announcing
that they were doing a fully animated
season and then we were like we would
hold on a minute maybe we could do maybe
an animated episode maybe we could do
this so it sort of started like that and
then joe was able to go away and think
about it and really hone it into how we
can actually make that work but we were
very excited when we realized that
there's something we could do
what did you think of seeing yourself in
animated form like that and i do think
you want to just do
now like some kind of animated series of
lucifer
um
we're laughing about that we've actually
thought maybe there's a maybe there is
an afterlife for lucifer here in a sort
of animated world but um it was
incredibly fun uh
and
when they started sending me the
sketches of what lucifer was going to
look like as a cartoon i just basically
joe was like how but like do you want
your chin to be and my notes were always
as
more but more but more but more but the
most the more but the better basically
for the chin i just felt like
less is not more in this circumstance
with this being the last season and the
last chance to
perform certain songs on the show was
there anything specific that you wanted
to make sure to work in before the
series was done
i don't think so i mean well actually
lady is a [ __ ] which i do with bob the
drag queens in episode two
um that is something that for years i've
kind of thought oh this would be really
fun for lucifer to do but we just never
found the right moment for it to happen
and then lo and behold there was a scene
with that and i was like
can we do this
um so yeah that version of the of lady
as a [ __ ] is something that i'd i'd
always wanted to do and wasn't sure we'd
ever get around to it um
uh but apart from that my my bucket list
of songs was pretty much ticked off when
we did the musical episode last season
yeah i love that uh that lady is a
traitor episode i mean that whole
musical number in that episode i thought
was so great
uh it was a lot of fun to do and bob was
just brilliant i mean it i'd had this
kind of like feeling about this song and
i didn't know how it was going to
manifest itself on the show but to do it
as a duet
with him and and the way that we did it
and the way that he you know brought his
his humor and um and unique kind of
voice to that version of it it was so
much fun to be part of and i remember on
the day because it was quite a sort of
you know filming for the crew was pretty
arduous at times during season six
because of the coveted stuff because
they were always in their masks and
their shields and any opportunity that
we had to make them laugh or like give
them a sort of give them a thrill was
great and i remember that day
that people just really enjoyed the
shooting of that scene because it was
something a bit different and it made
everyone smile so
job done
yeah
well with chloe and lucifer reunited at
the end of the season but where do you
think their time together
what do you think it looks like now what
is this new version of their partnership
gonna entail
oh i think you know she'll probably um
help him impart his wisdom upon the lost
souls of hell but i think you know they
can create whatever they want down in
hell so
hell isn't hell as we know it anymore
it's just it's just that what this place
is called it doesn't need to necessarily
be hellish so they can they can spend
their life together and of course you
know their their daughter is half angel
so she'll be there as well with them
whenever she wants to be
um and that's you know that's um that
makes me happy that they get to spend
eternity together
the hardest goodbye for me was the one
between lucifer and mays because there's
just so much that's not being said
between them
obviously you know they're they clearly
have an emotional bond
what was that seem like to shoot what
was it like to do that because it just
i just thought it was so emotionally
moving
um i'm getting hair standing up when
you're talking about it i because i
again it was
you know episode nine is probably my
favorite episode of of season six
the penultimate episode because that
episode
there are some really genuine moments on
the screen that was my last ever scene
with leslian
and so i didn't want to think too much
about it i wanted to exist in as much
truth as possible so we hardly rehearsed
it we hardly did anything about it and i
just wanted to treat it as i'm saying
goodbye to you
um and you know i'm saying goodbye and i
know you know i'm saying goodbye but
we're not saying that
and you know that for me those are what
was the most powerful moments with
actors actors
watching someone who you know wants to
cry but they're trying so hard not to is
much more interesting than watching
someone just gush
and so you know it's fraught with those
moments across the whole episode but
particularly with leslie anne in that
scene it just felt
because these are two characters that
don't really like talking about their
feelings very much
um and so like you say what wasn't said
in that in that scene really kind of
like um
just sort of simmers under the surface
constantly and it's really impactful and
you know i it was the whole episode for
me was quite cathartic because i
essentially was saying goodbye to
everybody
as tom and as lucifer and like those
moments we tried to keep as raw and
fresh on the screen as possible
along saying goodbye to the show and the
character you also had to leave
lucifer's corvette behind
[Laughter]
i know you
i know you would have taken the car home
with you if you could have but did you
ever get to borrow it while you were
making the show did you get
a moment goodbye
never i had to fight to drive the car in
the actual show from time to time
because they were like we've got a stunt
guy for this i'm like please let me
drive it
um
yeah no it was unfortunately not i do
believe that that car will probably be
um part of the warner brothers studio
tour when you go and see the sort of the
famous vehicles from all of our shows um
yes unfortunately not but i i loved that
car for so many reasons but one thing i
would say about it is it looks amazing
it is an absolute beast to drive it's
like doing a workout
yeah my father has a old mustang so i
know how difficult those cars can be to
drive
did you get a moment to say goodbye to
the car did you have a final moment
where you could just you know admire the
car
well i think again in that episode in
episode nine where we go out to the
beach um with as the family um that was
a kind of like big last day in the car
basically and again it was sort of felt
quite appropriate and also we had the
driving lesson with rory which was quite
sort of the handing over of the keys was
quite sort of symbolic
in that sense but um
but yeah no i i i will miss that car it
kind of
i remember seeing on day one of shooting
or day two shooting whenever we were
down at um
hollywood boulevard in the pilot and
that was kind of for me the missing
piece i had the suit i had everything
else i thought a lot about this
character and when this car rocked up i
was like yes i know exactly who this
character is
scott porter also joins the show this
season which again can't be an easy
thing to do and he really fits in quite
naturally
what did you most enjoy about what he
brought and what his character brought
to this season
um well i've known scott i did my first
ever pilot actually with scott back in
20 2009 so um it was lovely to have him
uh in that sense and have an old mate
there um but what he brought as the
character of carol was
again that kind of like someone who
wasn't in on it and it's always quite
fun
you know as a dynamic on the show
obviously we're talking about ella being
the last one to find out but there's
still a character who we introduce who's
still kind of like clueless that all
these people actually exist and are real
um in in the guys that they're claiming
so having someone there who is just a
very human very grounded aspect is
always really important in our
storytelling and um and scott brought
that in abundance and he's just you know
he's he's such a pro
he's just fitted right in he was great
what's it been like for you to
transition from doing lucifer to doing
your role in players
i mean has it been
did you notice an adjustment because
you are doing them closer together than
you know if you had taken some long
break in between
yeah i mean it was it was there was i
had that first the my first kind of
couple of weeks here when we were um
like having fittings and rehearsals and
all that sort of stuff
i can't i was sort of plagued in my head
with this notion of like i've forgotten
how to do this
i haven't played a new character for
such a long time i was sort of doubting
my choices and the way i felt about
stuff
um so i you know it was i was sort of
worrying myself to start with but then a
couple of days into shooting i was like
oh yeah this is how we go this is how we
do it and i've it's been really nice and
sort of it's been quite cathartic
process actually to sort of
move on and play somebody else because i
sort of worried about whether i'd be
able to do that again
um
but um no it's been it's been good and
i'm hoping that that um nick who i play
in players is quite different to lucifer
so
fingers crossed
yeah i mean what have you enjoyed about
the character about doing a sort of uh
romantic comedy feel
do you have
romantic comedies that you know favorite
romantic comedies of your own
i mean but rom-com was a genre that i
loved growing up and of course you know
i grew up during four weddings in a
funeral and all like notting hill the
richard curtis rom-coms were very
prevalent in my in my growing up but my
favorite rom-com and it's so amazing
that we're here in new york my favorite
rom-com was when harry met sally
and i have always loved that movie um
and
it's really amazing being in new york
where all these like iconic rom-coms
have happened over the years
um because it is a very sort of very
much a character in in the movie um
so i i don't know it's it's it's i'm
having a really nice time doing
something completely different
um
and
i don't know i i feel like you know six
years of doing lucifer spending so much
time on a set in front of cameras and
all that sort of stuff one thing i would
say is that i feel is that i feel less
nervous than i used to
walking onto onto a set and i feel ready
to play as opposed to try and get it
right
which is
quite a liberating feeling actually
i love nottingham because it always gave
me something when family or friends
didn't understand what i did for a
living i could always say well if you
kind of want to know what a press junk
it is go watch it
there you go exactly exactly maybe
something to refer people to
well have you already started to think
about
what you want to do after
this
do you
have something lined up are you reading
stuff like
are you thinking about that
i i mean i am i'm not i'm not in a rush
um you know there's been things that
have come my way and i've said no thank
you too because i just you know it was
so consuming for six years doing lucifer
that um
i'm not in a rush to go back and do a
like a long running tv show again
um i
one thing that i
um
that i think about a lot is that it was
a real gift to play one one character
for six years but one thing i i always
loved as an actor was playing different
people and having that variety
and so i'm i'm not going to rush to sign
up to a long-running character again but
i'd love to kind of like you know do
limited series and and and films and
theater and just kind of like you know
keep just playing different people
because that's that's what i really love
about this this job
is there a genre that you haven't worked
in yet that you have like a secret
desire to
do
well i mean i i you know lucifer sort of
made me fall in love with singing again
and before doing this job i don't think
i would ever really thought about doing
a musical for example but um that is
something i would love to do in my
future for sure
um
[Music]
and i wouldn't have been saying that to
you six years ago so there you go that's
probably answered that question i feel
like i'm ready for a musical
would you want to do a musical that
we're familiar with would you want to do
an original musical
i'd be open to both um
but yeah i mean
it's always for me it's always about the
material so if i respond to the material
then i'll want to do it um so we shall
see
well what do you think you'll miss most
about the show the cast this character
what do you think will be the hardest
thing once it finally fully sinks in to
have said goodbye to
um obviously you know the friends that i
made and the feeling that we had making
the show was really special
um
but i think just in terms of
an actor and as a job
but what i'm really gonna miss is just
every
day on lucifer i felt like i had the
opportunity to do something different to
kind of flex a different side of my
skill set
because it was just such a multi-faceted
character within a within a show that
was like
action comedy
serious dramatic beats
music you know i had everything so i i
don't think i'm gonna have so much
variety
in one character again and i'm really
going to miss that
yeah i mean that's one of the things i
always loved about the show is that it's
sort of every genre in one there's all
these things going on it's very
unexpected in that way i
never really knew where the next season
was going to take things and and that's
fun i mean you don't want to it's the
dick van dyke of tv shows that's what i
call it
a bit of everything
it's fun because it's not like you know
the sitcom you expected to sort of be
the same every week you expect the
characters to be the same and that the
laughs kind of have the same beats and
with the show like this i think the
total unexpected was really part of its
charm
oh absolutely because i think people
expected it to be exactly what you're
saying with that procedural element to
it and it's that you know it's that show
where this is the dynamic amongst our
characters this is what we solved this
week and when we come back next week it
will be a new thing to solve
now that would that would have been the
boring version of lucifer
but actually what we found was yeah
these are the jobs that they do and each
week we'll do this but that was just the
way to plot
how we then outside of that look at
these these characters lives and what
you know what's happening to them and
what they mean to each other and
it had this kind of constant journey and
this constant evolving narrative and
that was just uh that was that was my
favorite part of the show
well i appreciate you talking to me
about it again
it was
fun to watch this last season because it
is sort of wild
absolutely no idea the story points that
were coming so i just i thought it was a
lot of fun
yeah
thank you so much christina and thanks
for your support over the years as well
thank you it's been delightful to talk
to you about the show so thank you